c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir la situation au Burkina Faso
après un week-end de renversement coup
d'État et exil du colonel d'Amy Bao au
Togo le capitaine Traoré qui a pris le
pouvoir promet une transition rapide et
des assises le pays est-il en train de
sombrer dans la stabilité politique et
insécuritaire
décryptage dans un instant avec notre
invité Francis patine notre ancien
correspondant dans le pays
et puis le Tchad qui prolonge sa
transition de deux ans le chef de la
jinte m'a amenait débit et maintenu à la
tête de l'État et pourra briguer la
présidence cette prolongation s'est
décidé à l'issue du dialogue national
boycotté par une grande partie de
l'opposition et des organisations de la
société civile
il n'aura tenu que huit mois au pouvoir
avant de se faire déloger lui aussi par
un coup d'État le lieutenant-colonel
paul-henyba a fini par démissionner
contraint et forcée par le putsch d'un
capitaine Ibrahim Traoré il est
désormais en exil au Togo et appelle à
respecter les engagements pris avec la
CEDEAO les précisions de notre envoyé
spécial à Ouagadougou ange no manioc
le nouveau leader autoproclamé Ibrahim
Traoré a fait une annonce publique et
dimanche appelant la population à vaquer
à ses occupations quotidiennes et à
cesser tous les actes de vandalisme que
nous avons vu ce week-end et il semble
que les Burkinabè aient fait exactement
cela le trafic a repris les rues ont été
très animées bourdonnant de motos et de
piétons toute la journée les écoles en
même réouverts dans la capitale ainsi
que les magasins dans l'ensemble les
personnes à qui nous avons parlé sont
heureuses de ce retour à la stabilité et
la plupart d'entre elles ont exprimé
leur soutien à Ibrahim Traoré elle
disent avoir été frustrée par l'ancien
dirigeant de transition d'Amy bar et lui
reprochait de ne pas avoir réussi à
endiguer la menace terroriste qui a
paralysé la majeure partie de la nation
depuis 2015
et un nouveau président qui est venu
ce que nous attendons de lui
le premier mois c'est ainsi que
deuxièmement il n'a qu'à écouter les
populations là
parce que les populaires souffrent les
militaires souffrent
nous on veut que les souffrances
définies nous nous fatiguer de pleurer
une autre question importante ce sera la
transition politique dans le pays une
délégation de la Cedeao doit se rendre
au Burkina Faso mardi et l'on s'attend à
ce qu'elle reprenne les négociations là
où elles se sont arrêtées avec Damiba
qui avait accepté un retour à un régime
civil dans les deux prochaines années au
plus tard à Monsieur Traoré désormais
chargé de gérer les affaires courantes
du pays jusqu'à la nomination du
président il reste maintenant à savoir
si cette transition aura lieu quand dans
quelles conditions et qui sera nommé
vous l'avez entendu le colonel d'Amy va
être en exil au Togo on va l'écouter
l'objectif affiché était clair
interrompre la transition
devant les risques de division
et de fracture au sein de notre armée
et considérant les motivations profondes
de l'avènement du mpsr
et l'intérêt supérieur du Burkina Faso
en toute conscience et en pleine
responsabilité
j'ai renoncé pour compter de ce jour
2 octobre à ma fonction de chef de
l'État
français vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de l'Afrique merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau alors on
a entendu le colonel d'Amy bar il a dit
entre autres que le coup d'État c'est
pour rompre la transition le nouvel
homme fort du Burkina Faso Ibrahim
Traoré lui dit que le pouvoir de
l'intéresse pas lesquels des deux
faut-il croire pas principe je méfie de
la parole et des promesses des
prétoriens donc je pense qu'on jugera le
nouveau patron de du Burkina assez fait
juste au cours des prochaines semaines
alors est-ce que le Burkina vient de
faire un nouveau pas vers le précipice
avec ce coup d'État 8 mois après le
précédent coup d'État les coups d'État
ça doit être l'exception ça ne peut pas
être la règle le Burkina je crois depuis
son indépendance a connu peut-être une
quinzaine de coup d'état donc ça ne peut
pas être la règle ce qu'il faut c'est
mettre un terme à le pouvoir de revenir
au civil le coup d'État de janvier et
donc 202 Dieu était déjà un accroc à la
loi à la constitution celui qui vient
d'intervenir les tout autant donc comme
militaire remplace un autre on ne peut
pas passer notre temps en Afrique à ce
sport là et on parle de la transition et
le colonel d'Amy bas dit qu'il faut
suivre cette transition à respecter les
engagements privés est-ce que c'est
possible avec ce nouveau coup d'État
négociations avec la CEDEAO il y a un
cadre je pense qu'il faut tenir ce
rendez-vous faut tenir la promesse qui
est faite maintenant on ne peut pas
croire quelqu'un qui vient d'arriver au
pouvoir attendons de voir il y a des
gens quelque chose d'ailleurs vous savez
le capitaine Traoré est arrivé au
pouvoir l'âge où Thomas Sankara herri au
pouvoir en 83 Thomas Sankara avait
exactement 34 ans mais Thomas Sankara
c'était quelque chose il était plus
flamboyant il avait une formation
idéologique et il avait un peu plus de
rigueur on l'attend du capitaine donc
Traoré qu'il retienne c'est son
engagement et qu'il laisse la place
peut-être à quelqu'un d'autre dans le
bref délai en tout cas parmi les choses
qui précipitent cet instabilité
politique elle est aussi c'est c'est la
question en sécurité merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau je rappelle si
besoin que vous étiez notre
correspondant pendant des années au
Burkina Faso vous avez réalisé de
nombreux reportages et que vous avez vu
la situation se dégrader dans le pays on
peut dire aujourd'hui que le c'est le
sécuritaire qui détermine le politique
clairement
politique d'ailleurs les deux derniers
poutchistes on peut dire on justifié
leur coup d'État par le fait que leur
prédécesseur ne pouvait pas assurer la
sécurité du pays
d'amiba en janvier avait invoqué cet
argument envers rockabré
et Ibrahim Traoré le même argument
invoqué envers damibar ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ces deux attaques
précises qui ont
provoqué le départ de des deux derniers
présidents
recaboré c'était l'attaque d'une étage
je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez
c'était au mois de il me semble c'était
au mois de novembre novembre 2021 une
attaque c'est pas une attaque c'était un
des soldats qui avait envoyé une note
disons qu'ils avaient pu de nourriture
qu'il avait plus de vivre qu'ils
allaient même chasser le gibier pour
manger ils ont été attaqués par des
groupes djihadistes et ça fait 50 morts
ça fait un grand retentissement Burkina
Faso et ça a provoqué la chute de
rocaboré et là c'est encore une attaque
mais l'attaque contre un convoi à gaz
Guinée et gaskindé c'est dans la région
du son pas loin de Djibo et l'attaque
cette attaque a eu lieu en début de
semaine dernière l'année 150 camions ont
été incendiés officiellement et le 11
morts une cinquantaine disparu et c'est
cette attaque même d'amiba le dit
lui-même dans son discours qui a
provoqué sa chute donc on peut dire que
le souci vient principalement de la
région du sum il y a une route la route
nationale 22 c'est cette route qui est
quasiment inaccessible aujourd'hui au
Burkina Faso c'est une route qui mène
deux Ouagadougou à la région du sum à
Djibo vous pouvez le voir sur l'écran le
9 août dernier à Nancy gare sur cette
route il y a eu une attaque contre des
militaires qui a fait 15 mois et le 26
septembre ça gaz Kindé une attaque
contre un convoi de vivre qui a fait 11
morts et 50 disparus mais cette route
est essentielle pour amener des vivres
dans la ville de Djibo card Djibo c'est
une ville symbolique aujourd'hui au
Burkina Faso alors justement j'aimerais
qu'on s'arrête un petit peu sur cette
ville vous avez effectué une mission à
Djibo une ville tombée entre les mains
des djihadistes depuis février dernier
et qui n'est toujours pas revenu sous
l'autorité de l'État burkinaboué dit
beau c'est un peu symptomatique du
malaise dans le pays tout d'abord c'est
une ville symbolique parce que c'est
dans cette ville qui a été créé le
premier groupe burkinabe en saoules en
2016 et malheureusement elle est vue par
beaucoup de monde au Burkina excès au
Burkina comme la ville de djihadistes et
Djibo aujourd'hui j'ai contacté certains
personnes qui habitent à Dibo au compte
de la famille hadibo aujourd'hui Dibo
est coupé du Burkina Faso ça fait plus
de peut-être deux trois semaines qu'il
n'y a pas eu de vivre des personnes
meurent de faim d'ailleurs
il y a des mamans ton ancien appel
dimanche matin des mers sont sortis en
centre-ville de Thibault pour réclamer
de la nourriture car leur enfant
mourrait de faim il n'y a pas de
médicaments il n'y a pas de nourriture
les prix des denrées alimentaires ont
explosé il y a eu de l'inflation pour
garder personne on voulait spéculer je
prends juste un dernier exemple le prix
par exemple de lui il est passé de 1000
francs à 2030 donc c'est cette situation
sécuritaire aussi qui plonge le pays
dans cette instabilité politique c'est
aussi à cause de cette insécurité que
l'on voit c'est coup d'État se
multiplier malgré tout on va s'arrêter
un instant sur le retour à la normale
notre correspondant notre envoyé spécial
en parlait tout à l'heure les événements
de ce week-end qui ont plongé le pays
dans l'incertitude n'a pas empêché les
écoliers de reprendre le chemin de
l'école la rentrée scolaire a été
maintenue malgré l'inquiétude des
parents Laurent berthetcher
alors que le calme revient peu à peu à
Ouagadougou c'est doux n'y en pas amène
ses enfants à l'école en ce jour de
rentrée se perd de famine ne peut
réprimer son anxiété suite au coup
d'État de vendredi un peu d'inquiétude
bon avec la situation du pays
bon nous notre souhait le souhait des
parents c'est que ça aille normalement
un retour à la normale que les
professeurs de cette école font tout
pour mettre en œuvre après avoir chanté
l'hymne national et répondu présent à
l'appel les enfants retrouvent leur
salle de classe où ils reprennent les
cours avec enthousiasme et pour certains
un peu d'ennuis
malgré quelques regards inquiets la
journée se déroulent sans incident une
victoire pour l'administration qui
refuse que les événements du week-end ne
viennent perturber la rentrée nous ne
pouvons pas être sûr à 100%
mais nous aurons croire que tel que les
choses
se sont passées et nous pouvons penser
que s'il peut être à Dieu nous allons
pouvoir boucler et commencer et vous
plaît l'année en toute quiétude chaque
année de plus en plus d'enfants se
retrouvent des scolarisés en Afrique
centrale et en Afrique de l'Ouest
victime de l'insécurité qui sévit dans
ces régions l'UNICEF estime qu'environ
11000 écoles ont dû fermer au Sahel et
dans la région du lac Tchad à cause des
guerres et des violences
Francis patiney on a on a eu l'occasion
d'inviter le ministre burkinabé de
l'éducation Lionel bilgo qui était sur
ce plateau et qui avait fait un
plaidoyer pour appeler la communauté
internationale à aider le Burkina Faso
et le Sahel il disait que en quelques
mois la communauté internationale a
débloqué 13 milliards pour l'Ukraine et
que ça faisait 7 ans que le Sahel 69
millions d'habitants trois pays des
trois frontières attendaient
2,1 milliard de dollars et qu'il y avait
deux poids de mesure
c'est un fait on peut le constater mais
en revanche comment la communauté
internationale peut-elle continuer à
aider un pays qui qui multiplie les
coups d'État fournir de l'argent des
armes à un pouvoir qui a pris le pouvoir
par la force
du point de mesure c'est inacceptable
c'est on l'a vu au Kosovo on l'a vu dans
d'autres situations c'est sûr que la
misère africaine la misère du sermon
intéresse très peu et qu'on met beaucoup
plus de l'argent pour ces semblables il
faut
oser le dire et les gens qui vous
ressemblent les gens qui sont à
proximité et c'est le cas de l'Ukraine
ukrainien souffre c'est vrai mais il y a
des gens en Afrique au Sahel
particulièrement qui s'ouvre beaucoup
plus alors le second vous voulez c'est
savoir si la communauté internationale
peut aider un pays qui
a par la force
[Musique]
offre lois aidé ces pays à stopper le
terrorisme merci beaucoup Francis
patiney on parle aussi du coup de de la
transition au Tchad elle a été prolongée
de deux ans et son président le chef de
la jinte Mohamed Idriss Déby et maintenu
une décision à l'issue du dialogue
national boycoté par une grande partie
de l'opposition la correspondance à une
Jama de Mamadou
et le général
Idriss Déby Itno pourrait se présenter
aux prochaines échéances électorales qui
devraient clôturer cette seconde face de
la transition telle est la décision de
la première du dialogue national
inclusif et souverain la communauté
internationale dans sa majorité à savoir
l'Union européenne et les ambassades des
pays représentés au chat ainsi que les
États-Unis et l'Angleterre ont réagi par
voie de communiquer sur salut tous les
travaux du dialogue et leur conclusion
ils émettent par contre des réserves sur
l'éligibilité des membres du Conseil
militaire transition se rangeant ainsi
derrière la décision de l'Union
africaine qui fixe la période de 18 mois
pour l'achèvement de la transition et la
non participation aux élections futures
des membres du Conseil militaire de
transition pour la majorité des
participants au dialogue à qui nous
avons parlé illégibilité des membres du
CMT n'est pas important ce qui importe
c'est mettre en place des institutions
assez fortes capables de garantir des
élections libres transparentes et
crédibles
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi merci à Khalid Houssine notre
ancien correspondant et expert du
Burkina Faso merci beaucoup Francis
patiney spécialiste de l'Afrique merci
d'avoir été notre invité restez avec
nous dans quelques instants à la suite
de Paris direct
[Musique]